[Música]
pra mim é uma alegria aqui em joão
pessoa porque a história que vou contar
pra vocês começa justamente aqui no rio
2 no nordeste
meus avós nasceram aqui no nordeste
foram para são paulo e deram nascença
essa mulher aqui do meu lado
esses dois são meus pais e hoje ainda
como adulto eu tenho uma dificuldade
extrema de entender como eles passaram
por tanto perrengue durante a vida
inteira principalmente financeira e me
deu sempre uma educação de qualidade
ele sempre priorizar a educação isso pra
mim foi uma gratidão gigantesca que eu
tive
e como vocês ouviram teve uma coisa que
eu fiz da terceira série ao 3º ano do
colegial e essa coisa foi recuperação na
terceira série foi de recuperação para
fazer todas as lições de casa que não
tinha feito até então
mas na sétima série eu não fiquei de
operação que eu peguei a catapora então
eles deixaram em casa eu pude passar por
isso
só que teve uma experiência que passei
com 19 anos de idade mudou completamente
minha perspectiva sobre educação
desde então eu nunca tinha tido um
propósito motivo para realmente estudar
só que quando foi contratado pela
microsoft com 19 anos eu passei três
meses só estudando
então eu trabalhava das 9 horas da manhã
às seis horas da tarde eu era pago só
para estudar isso mudou completamente
minha perspectiva porque voltava para
casa de ônibus com uma apostila lendo eu
sonhava com tela e todo meu propósito
era se eu estudar mais ainda eu vou
poder ajudar outra pessoa para o outro
lado e isso mudou completamente minha
visão sobre educação hoje tem um baita
orgulho de voltar pra casa tem uma série
de livros em um instante mas foi quando
nesse processo eu fui escolhido com 21
anos de idade para ser instrutor das
pessoas trabalhavam comigo não era
profissionais extremamente geniais de 33
35 38 anos de idade estão aprendendo
como leque de 21 anos e esse aqui foi a
último dia que estava no escritório
porque estava construindo uma startup
estava construindo a espiral do
conhecimento porque eu queria ensinar
tanto essas pessoas eu queria ensinar
tanto
eles que eu queria um canal no youtube
para colocar todos os vídeos de todas as
ideias que tinha tecnologia de tudo que
eu tinha recebido tinha certeza que ia
passar pra frente
e foi isso em dois meses dentro de um
apartamento de 50 metros quadrados onde
eu literalmente tinha uma cama uma
privada e um chuveiro
eu lavava louça no chuveiro eu construí
nesses 80 vídeos para publicar para o
mundo inteiro pra quem falava em
português e tecnologia de forma
acessível mas foi muito rápido que eu
descobri que no youtube
eu não ia ganhar dinheiro só que esses
mesmos vídeos acabaram na mão de um dono
de uma faculdade de são paulo e foi lá
quando fui conhecer ele foi bater um
papo com ele e assim eu já passei um
vídeo pra todos os meus coordenadores e
eles adoraram os vídeos
fui caracas se eu soubesse nunca teria
colocado exato a mão e foi quando ele me
convidou para trabalhar na fiap e na
empresa nasce na universidade e ele
falou assim vamos construir um projeto
onde a gente possa colocar todo o
conhecimento da universidade graça para
as pessoas estão assistindo
e a gente começou o projeto fx e o
primeiro curso que eu criei lá foi para
ensinar pessoas a construir aplicativos
de uma maneira simples de maneira rápida
de maneira fácil as pessoas conseguiam
construir suas primeiras soluções porque
não sei se vocês sabem mas a maior taxa
de evasão de uma faculdade de tecnologia
são pessoas que não têm lógica de
programação e nem entendem por que estão
fazendo aquilo lá foi quando construir
esse esse curso e as pessoas que mais
assistiram não eram as pessoas do
primeiro ano eram os alunos da escola do
lado
foi quando ele falou assim vamos juntar
esse pessoal e fazer uma maratona de
aplicativos ou seja vamos desafiar esses
jovens do ensino médio para que eles
possam construir soluções para a
educação dentro da escola dentro da
escola dentro da sala de aula ou do
brasil inteiro e foi quando eu tive uma
das maiores prazeres da minha vida que
foi entregar um prêmio por guilherme
esse garoto está no meio da foto que eu
dei pra ele uma educação vitalícia
dentro da faculdade que eu tinha feito
ou seja toda a educação que eu tive que
eu tive o prazer eu tive o presente de
ter na minha vida eu estava passando
aqui lá por guilherme eficiência que eu
quero fazer por essa minha vida foi
quando em 2014 eu conheci minha sócia
atual ea gente pegou esse
o projeto da maratona de aplicativos e
expandir o brasil inteiro todos os
estados do brasil tinha um representante
da maratona e alunos do ensino médio
estão construindo soluções que eles viam
dentro das suas escolas
e aí em 2015 a gente chegou a 10 mil
jovens do brasil inteiro e esses jovens
estavam construindo aplicativos para
resolver problemas de educação e o que
era extraordinário foi quando na última
edição que a gente fez a maratona de
aplicativos
a gente conheceu esse grupo e os
aplicativos que eles construíam iam
desde a tia da cantina descobrir qual
era o troco que ela tinha que dá até
jovens autistas têm uma rotina e esses
jovens aqui eles foram pra pagar eles
foram construir o aplicativo foi validar
foi construir junto com os alunos
autistas
só que o que mais me impressiona foi que
essa final foi na final no escritório do
google e no escritório do google ele
estavam tirando foto lado de android no
mais e quando eles se encontraram
eles começaram a se cumprimentar e se
apresentar é preciso que se conhece eles
falam sim a gente conhece
só que virtualmente morava em são
sebastião onde morava em santos
enfim é só que extraordinário às pessoas
que construíram uma solução espetacular
para alunos autistas nunca tinham se
encontrado só tinham se encontrado
virtualmente e aí tinha sido lançado o
desafio para o nosso lado a gente tinha
de uma forma ou outra ensinada 15 mil
pessoas a programar essas pessoas
obviamente elas foram fazer jornalismo
medicina inclusive tecnologia mas do
outro lado um monte de startup um monte
de corporação um monte de multinacional
bate à nossa porta precisando desses
profissionais
foi quando decidiu construir a martek ea
master tech a pergunta que a gente fez
desde o primeiro dia é que continua com
a gente até agora que é como que a gente
pode capacitar profissionais em
habilidades do século 21
pra quem não sabe essa habilidade por 21
foram mapeadas pelo fórum econômico
mundial em 2015
a gente acredita que a gente tem duas
respostas para essa pergunta são duas
partes a primeira delas é o foco nas
habilidades certas
ou seja a gente ensina tecnologia e
negócios digitais marketing digital eo
ex design
porque se a gente colocar esses quatro
profissionais dentro de uma sala eles
criam uma startup eles que uma empresa
não quiserem construir uma empresa eles
têm 406 mil vagas abertas no brasil hoje
para poder trabalhar em cima disso e o
segundo ponto é a metodologia certa e um
final de semana a gente às vezes com
mais de mil jovens
a gente já ensinou eles no sábado a
construir seu primeiro site e no domingo
a construir seu primeiro aplicativo
eles saem de lá no domingo com o
aplicativo no bolso e isso eu chamo
jovens de 15 anos que são games que é o
que vocês devem ter pensado até senhora
de 65 anos se colas que construir um
aplicativo delas
essa aqui foi nossa primeira turma é
nossa primeira foto com a gente começou
a trabalhar a nossa grande inovação foi
comprar esses dois monitores do rio
bolso mas as pessoas começaram a falar
com a gente porque estava a ser
parecendo apresentação ali setembro de
2015 vão lançar um mês aqui um mês
depois a gente já estava com quatro
pessoas ea gente já se achava uma
empresa porque tinha uma impressora já
passando dali em novembro de 2015 tinha
recém contratado minha mãe porque foi
assim eu preciso que alguém seja a mãe
dos nossos alunos e até hoje a gente
trabalha no prédio com mais de 800
pessoas
as pessoas ainda é chamada de mãe da
lena que o nome dela madalena e aí a
gente brinca que a gente possa tirar
foto começou a trabalhar
e esse aqui foi um dia memorável para
mim quando a gente é contratado oito
pessoas de uma vez só
eles não tinham computador não tinha
lugar para sentar mas a gente estava
completamente animado da quantidade de
volume que estava conseguindo fazendo
master técnica
hoje este tipo de 33 pessoas e por mais
incrível que pareça muito do que a gente
aprende com essa pessoa esse pessoal é
espetacular
a gente pra equipe crescer tão rápido em
dois anos e meio
a gente mudou muitas vezes de escritório
e da última mudança que a gente fez de
escritório a gente viu um problema que a
equipe de gestão do prédio tá batendo
junto com a equipe de limpeza que
acontecia apesar de todas as planilhas
de gestão apesar de todas as
metodologias que estava importando do
mundo inteiro
a equipe de gestão do prédio não
conseguia conversar com a equipe de
limpeza e eles chegaram então num sábado
para fazer aquele time aquela reunião de
feedback paraná aquela bronca
só que eles descobriram um problema a
equipe de limpeza não sabia ler
a maior dificuldade é essa
eles vieram falar com a gente
e quando falaram com a gente assim a
gente tem uma professora de português
que trabalha junto com a gente
que tal a gente pegar dois dias na
semana uma hora e eles aprenderem a ler
e escrever junto com a gente e pessoas
que nunca tiveram graduação na vida
fizeram uma gradação no meio do
escritório foi espetacular energia deles
a energia que eles tinham a vontade que
eles tinham e aí não consegue falar
assim as pessoas conseguem aprender não
importa a idade
e aí por essa vaga e por essa energia
que o pessoal continua colocando a um
mês atrás a gente foi selecionado como
startup mais atraente do mercado
brasileiro
isso por conta da quantidade de
transformações que a gente faz das
empresas da transformação que a gente
faz junto com as pessoas têm um projeto
que eu sou apaixonado eu tenho que falar
sobre ele
o facebook não selecionou para capacitar
1.600 jovens em tecnologia e essas
pessoas pessoas que normalmente não
teriam dinheiro de pagar a master
técnico e eu queria que você separar se
nessa foto
por que um dos grandes problemas que a
gente tem em tecnologia é a
representatividade de mulheres
olha só a primeira filha segunda fila é
extraordinário que a gente consegue
fazer o que a gente consegue atrair as
pessoas para fazerem e mais do que isso
como eu falei que eu coloquei minha mãe
pra trabalhar também
eu cheguei coloquei minha futura esposa
também para aprender programa no final
de semana
construiu seu aplicativo e fez em todo o
processo e aí o que a gente faz de mais
extraordinário
a gente coloca esses jovens como
protagonistas muito mais do que mostrar
para eles que eles conseguem programar é
mostrar para eles que eles conseguem
resolver os problemas de onde eles vivem
a gente tem sim mais os mil aplicativos
que já foram construídos pelos nossos
alunos
eles já têm mais de 50 mil downloads 100
mil downloads
mas o que eu sou realmente grato pelos
aplicativos que são construídos para
resolver o problema local o problema que
ele vê
chegou uma hora que a gente foi para uma
escola etec de itaquera fica na
periferia de são paulo e os jovens
apresentaram os projetos que eles
construíram e dentre esses projetos
as coordenadoras e as diretoras da
escola estão assistindo quando terminou
ela estava em lágrimas e elas falaram
seguinte
se vocês continuarem com
essas idéias que vocês procuram 95% dos
problemas que a gente tem na escola vão
ser resolvidos e o que a gente aprendeu
e que gente entendeu que todo final de
curso que a gente faz mas sem esses
1.600 jovens
a gente coloca eles num palco como esse
para que eles possam apresentar suas
idéias e quem recebe eles são 180
pessoas a cada turno são obviamente pais
mães e familiares mas também pessoas que
querem contratar são empreendedores são
sonhadores querem junto com eles
construir um brasil melhor que eu mais
me alegra a quantidade de energia que a
gente vem construindo junto com essa
comunidade que está construindo na
master tech
obviamente são dois anos e meio e mais
de 3 mil alunos que a gente capacitor
não por nossa competência mas por conta
da comunidade que a gente vai gerando
alunos que aprenderam a programar no
final de semana voltam para ensinar
outros alunos do programa para ajudar
como ninjas como pessoas incluídas no
meio do da equipe para que eles possam
falar assim você consegue sim dá pra
fazer
dá para aprender a programar um final de
semana você também consegue fazer isso
todo esse é o nosso processo o que a
gente é mais alegre do que a gente
consegue de culpar muito da metodologia
que a gente faz é que toda vez que a
gente vai para um escritório de fundo de
investimento quando ele vai ler um livro
de empreendedorismo todo mundo fala um
produto um mercado um preço vai para o
mercado
só que a educação a gente sabe que não é
assim a transformação ela tem que ser
completa
ela tem que ser presencial no corpo a
corpo ela tem que ser online ea gente
inclusive chegar em joão pessoa e ela
também tem que ser dentro das empresas
porque a gente ficou cansado de ver
tantas pessoas completamente capacitados
muito bem capacitadas mas completamente
insatisfeitos com o trabalho
por isso que a gente faz essas
transformações lá dentro também
e a gente tem certeza que talvez a gente
não possa transformar o brasil mas a
gente tem certeza que os nossos alunos
bom obrigado
[Aplausos]